this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman dust and
doctor are you here hey Dustin doctor by
the way it's a pretty cool usually
backwards right dr. Dustin usually yeah
my girlfriend is shelling out but attend
the show with our friends Meghan jonlizz
and Aaron to celebrate Michelle's
birthday a year and a half ago Michelle
and I moved from Dallas to Los Angeles
and I introduced her to my favorite
podcast that always cheered me up after
a rough day Hollywood babble-on she has
absolutely fallen in love with the show
and has noted every one of Ralph's
impressions while she's been listening
and she gets equally perturbed as you
Ralph with the eight impressions joke
yeah Kevin are you one of those people
this is podcast and if I'm like he does
I didn't pressured you like it's wrong
he just 18 because I'm so you're
listening wrong man for the record
Michelle's count is 62 as of last week's
episode boom 62 episodes of the
podcasters no sixty-two impressions Wow
how's that pot did you bring an
annotated list what you did
[Applause]
never expected that hey I bet you didn't
ah do you have it come on up let's go
through it then what is it bring up your
phone come on up
I I don't think I did say I do sixty two
impressions by the way I don't think so
either
but she got them all written down all
right come on up man come on up come up
here like a model traveler know you're
gonna read them come up here come here
come on you lost your voice how
convenient
yeah see all right here good Kevin
Karina Ralph Garman impressions are
these alphabetical by the first name
here we go Aaron Neville check Adam West
check I'll put this could be long you
might want to sit down al pacino always
the phone back if you like
I can't believe yeah what'd you go sit
down we'll get back to she literally did
write them all down and you're so nice
to be like give us your phone [ __ ] off
yeah well we'll take good care of it all
right here we go Aaron Neville check
Adam West check al pacino check Arnold
Schwarzenegger check I mean this one is
just as Australian accent so I guess
check
crikey Kevin don't be a didgeridoo
I guess it's it's an impression tiny
kangaroo down mate one could say that's
an impression of an Australian I guess
that counts Beetlejuice check bill cosby
well not anymore of a check Bobcat
Goldthwait check british accent check
c-3po
when the [ __ ] did you ever do c-3po I do
him all the time Kevin I'll ask again
when the [ __ ] have you ever done c-3po I
think that just falls under your British
accent in general cesar romero the joker
yes Charlton Heston yes Christopher
Walken yes [ __ ] is given Yeah right
David Bowie is my waxed ass now David
Lynch yes Doc Brown yes Donald Trump yes
Dudley Moore yes Edwin yes
et what the [ __ ] extra-terrestrial
you do et bro you can't just say movie
lines and then call it an impression
like isn't that the definition of
impression doing behind that someone
else does shouldn't it sound sort of
like the thing it came from when you do
not ground never say Marty that's
unacceptable
this is your this your le in that movie
what do you want it you want to do so
look we it sounds like where they find
et in a bar I'm a cop I'm not gonna
check off et alright 61 voices then are
you happy
foghorn leghorn I say boy I say you know
about a shop at the bowling ball you
can't just be loud
you gotta sound like the [ __ ] works
for you foghorn yeah
foghorn leghorn I ain't givin that one
approval Frank Gorshin
from Batman of course Frank Sinatra yes
George from the Beatles I guess you do
all the Beatles we proved that Gilbert
Godfried yes grandpa Simpson yes I've
heard Harrison Ford has been crossed off
the list
check Hermey the elf um Rudolph I want
to be a dentist it's pretty good
you took me right there Homer Simpson
I've heard is good
Irish accent of course I do an Irish
accent oh I'm sorry can I just add
insulting Irish accent Jar Jar Binks mr.
Mars we know John Lennon yes Keanu
Reeves yes Kermit yes Louis black yes
Mike Tyson yes [ __ ] you're right man
Nicolas Cage yes Nick Nolte yes Norm
Macdonald Norman you do it Norm
Macdonald oh yay yes I do Kevin oh yeah
I'm doing arigato
yeah it's more like an Old MacDonald
okay Paul McCartney yes pee-wee Herman
you asked Pennywise yes Peter Falk from
Columbo yes Porky Pig what have you ever
done yeah I do it oh now you're grading
them there you go that's Porky Pig
Quasimodo yes r2d2 come on man
you're like those actors that put on
their resume a special skill
whistling Ray Romano yeah oh I was good
Raymond from Raymond yes Ringo Starr yes
Ronald Reagan well there you go again
Kevin thinking that I and I haven't done
something which I absolutely have done
and you [ __ ] look like into Wow
scooby-doo Scottish accent Sean Connery
shaggy yeah I guess if you could do like
going Scoob
I'm really scared southerner southern
drawl y-you know I can do that I'll be
your huckleberry
Stanley you have a Stan Lee excelsior
spider-friends
I mean I met the guy I don't sound like
that Swedish Chef bored bored bored and
I think everybody could do that
impression Sylvester Stallone yes German
yes Teletubby I keep that from the list
don't be doing that Frank N Furter would
eat you but Woody Allen yes it's
unbelievable it I can't believe I get so
neurotic when I do it though very kind
are you a teenager very important that I
know did not talk to you then yeah
Ralph's the rude one and then the last
one is Yoda you know of course you got a
Yoda hmm
yo did I do do Woody Allen as Yoda do
not do this no try vice-versa
hmm I might have given you a stroke man
you try to jab those two [ __ ]
together
go ahead mmm teenage girls I like
horrible yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]